each year Microsoft Research hosts
hundreds of influential speakers from
around the world including leading
scientists renowned experts in
technology book authors and leading
academics and makes videos of these
lectures freely available
hello everyone and good morning in to
our research talks and the new building
and 99 let me just moved in a week ago
so this is actually the first that I had
talked that I'm hosting here and I'm
very grateful to be able to host the gun
chin who is coming from Singapore
University and we have actually a little
bit history together because I looked
into his earlier work on on size types
and then we both moved on into a
verification and you will talk a little
bit about verification of heat
properties using his work on separation
logic and welcome an event is so this
piece of work is joint work with my two
students who high and Kristina and also
my collaborator at Durham's and chow so
is a work that we started about two
years ago doing automated verification
using separation logic so the basically
the goal of this world is to try to
handle mutable data structures with
sophisticated invariance in as precise
away as possible and then we also want
to capture various properties about this
kind of data structures like lang hi
maybe back properties and then here the
challenge we face here looking into it
is first we want to be able to perform
strong updates in tracking the
properties of these data structures in
the presence of aliasing and also we won
the facility to be as flexible as
possible allowing user to define
predicates about their data structure
and our emphasis is as much as possible
on a practical tool for verification and
here as I was mentioning we rely on
what has been done before in the area of
separation logic let me just give a very
brief background first about separation
logic I guess most of you in the
audience may have some knowledge that
I'll be very quick we just to slice
firstly separation logic is extension of
whole logic that will allow us to reason
about mutable data structures and
foundations for this work has been done
by people heard Reynolds and they are
collaborators around the above seven
years ago so those are the foundation
papers and essentially the extension of
the separation logic allow you to have
two main connective one is called
spatial conjunction which allows you to
describe are two formulas about disjoint
heap and then the other thing is spatial
implication that allows you to if you up
man you're currently with some
additional heap structure you should be
able to assert things from there and
this spatial implication is quite used
to especially if you are wanting to
reason backwards in your programs so as
we are mainly focusing on the forward
analysis here will be mainly using in
this work spatial conjunction operator
so just a quick example about the
separation formula as it was introduced
by a random in the leeks 2002 paper here
is a formula that says that you have a
variable X pointing to a memory location
two pieces of consecutive memory
location containing the value 3 and Y so
that's just the point to formula and
over here is the representation in in
the actual heap where X is pointing to
this to memory location with contents
tree and why and if you use the spatial
conjunction operator and write two
formulas there then what not you
essentially capturing is the first
formula is to capture this part and then
the second formula is to capture the
disjoint heap
and because this content here is the
same as Y and this content here is the
same as X you get a cyclic structure
built that way but if you did not want
to use the spatial conjunction but
instead you use just the normal
conjunction then what you may
effectively mean is you would like this
two piece of formula to apply to the
same heap so that could mean just a
simpler structure that is cyclic and it
also alias to each other so our approach
in this world I'll just give a very
brief outline and then after that talk
to you about the main techniques that we
have you know how to verify how to do
proving of separation formulas and
approximation and then later on how we
improve the expressivity a lot system so
our work here are mainly is focused on
capturing proper piece of data
structures and also on the invariance of
data structures allowing us to express
things like the height balance or the
nurse in the data structure and then
tracking them and to do that we allow
users to define their own predicates
about data structures and in particular
we allow these predicates to be
inductive or recursive in nature so that
it can express interesting thing and one
of the key part in our system is a song
and film improver for separation logic
which we have implemented and which we
have also extended with various feature
to make it more expressive and here we
are not going for completeness in our
proving we are just going for soundness
and then perhaps adding on techniques
that will make it as expressive as
possible in a nutshell our system really
contain two parts I guess most
verification system will contain this
two-part firstly there is the verifier
part that takes the code and then
generate various proof obligation and
then secondly an impalement proven that
will allow us the reason about those
public
creations the difference here since we
are based on separation logic is our
entailment program must be able to have
the separation formulas and we expect
the users of course to provide your own
code and also a proposed specification
for both methods and loops and then if
you are describing certain data
structures you're expected to also write
predicates about those data structures
and lastly to make it expressive we
allow users to write landmass about this
predicate maybe this relationship
between one predicate another the user
can provide that lamb are linking this
predicate together and then our system
will automatically prove that land mine
also apply that lemma where possible or
where needed so just a bit of example on
some of the data structures that can be
expressed using separation formula
firstly here is just a singular singly
linked linked list data structure in
which you have a root pointer pointing
to the beginning of this link list and
then towards the end of the linkage
there is a now reference so you have a
an ultimate terminated linked list and
we can capture this by this predicate
here ll together with a parameter that
indicate the Lang of this link list and
to express this you really need two
cases you need a base case that say if
the root pointer is now then the linked
list is of zero length or if the root
pointer is pointing to a note that means
it's not now then you also expect to
have a separate component here which is
the rest of the linked list that is
referenced from this next few year and
then the rest of the linked list will
have length n minus 1 so that's the
definition of that predicate and we
expect here a root parameter by default
which will which is the initial pointer
to your data structure and then the
other thing that we allow the user
supply in order to make the predicate
more information is some pure invariant
that we expect the hole for the
parameters of the predicate so in this
case you expect
that the list to be a you know non-empty
to be of a positive length zero or more
so this invariant will be supplied by
the user and our system will check that
this predicate in fact will satisfy this
invariant let's look at a slightly
different data structure this time a
little bit more complex with more
properties in particular we expect this
leads to be now sorted and we expect
this list to be a non-empty okay and the
kind of properties we may be tracking
for this data structure obviously the
lang the minimum and maximum value of
this sort the list and we have two cases
one is just a singleton note so this is
a single terminal where is now
terminated and then here we expect the
value itself to be minimum and also
maximum and the length to be one so this
is user specified and then in the
recursive case the first thought will
contain the minimum value but the rest
of the sorted list will contain the
value K which is just an exponential
value and also can capture the maximum
value in the rest of the linked list and
then in order for this linkage to be
sorted we have this property at pasture
this is kind of a invariant about this
data structure that we capture that the
minimum value will be less than the next
value K so that's expected in the
software English and then the pure
invariant that is true about this
predicate is just this is not now and
also mean is less than or equal to max
so we expect a you know this to describe
assault at least just to describe the
minimum maximum and then the length of
the sort of is and also it's non empty
another example so instead of just yup
sure
so so in if you use a normal conjunction
in the intuitionistic separation logic
framework then this note be in fact
alias with the rest of the linked list
not now has to be made me alias yeah if
you depending on whether you are saying
is classical separation logic or in
Futuristics separation logic so if it is
intuitionistic it means to me alias
because the the heats may overlap but in
this case if you use a separation
conjunction it means is completely
disjoint so you know they are not going
to a less you could be defining
something that is false so that's
something that you you may end up with
if you're not careful so this is the
content of the first value and the next
few usually the note contains two three
one is a value there there's the next
few so a is the content and then r is
the pointer to the next few so I didn't
gave the definition I just assume this
is something that we permit me may have
encountered before okay so if you
introduce a new girl they all that
existentially quantified like the cake
yeah I mean you could explicitly write
extension quantification in or in our
system whenever something is free that
is not bound to this parameter you will
be considered to be exponentially
quantify so we have some defaults that
minimize writing extension
quantification but if to be precise and
street you may want to write a
exponential quantification where you you
know you expect them so here is another
example slightly a more general but this
time you just lease fragment so instead
of ending with and now you end with a
you know a pointer P then in that case
the base case is rude is equal to P and
then the length of this segment is 0
otherwise it is a note with our pointing
to the rest of the segment and of course
that segment and with P so you write a p
day and this kind of this segment is
quite useful for example if you would
like to define a circular circular list
then in that case you will have a
segment here you have an initial hit
note here and then you'll have a segment
here and you expect the the last pointer
to point back through the with the first
node and that is defined by just saying
you have a first node and then a list
segment and this thing is pointing back
to the beginning of the cycle Earl
English and this case is non-empty
circular english and then invariant that
you may want to put is angry that I
equal to one if you put n greater than
equal to 0 it will be less information
and then you will of course it's still
sound except that you you know has less
information in your reasoning so is
advantageous for you to put as strong
and invariant as possible for your shape
practice in general here is another
example this time is for a tree and this
is also a high balanced tree and we are
capturing just the height here
such that if the root is now the high is
zero if the root is non now we will have
a left three and the right three with
their respective high and then we have a
formula here to tell us how to compute
the high and also we have a balance I
property this is that the height between
the two sub tree you know is either
minus 1 0 or 1 so it's kind of
constrained to be at least and most one
either the same high or 11 different
from pechanga and in this case you have
a also invaded for the high so so those
are the examples and if you look at this
separation formulas they are really two
parts in the formula the first part is
on the heat that describes the shapely
data structures okay so there's a heat
part and then there's the pure part
which essentially in our case cover size
property point the property and also
back property we allow banks of values
to be captured in our formula and of
course you can have also other property
depending on the proven that you have
whether they are able to deal with them
you can have a lease property and some
other property and the other
distinguishing part in our predicate is
we our default parameter the root
parameter is expected to be the
beginning of the data structure and we
also expect we have some property they
expect that all notes in this in our
predicate area describing is reachable
from the root pointer okay so now that
this this introduction is made on our
push in general let's go on to the
verification and then also the proving
path so for verification we aim for some
automation as long as the users provide
pre post conditions to each method and
loop ok and so let's pretty standard and
then the kind of check that we perform
is we check that every call site has
their precondition satisfy and also for
every method the post condition will be
satisfied at the end of the method and
then the other thing about our
approach to verification is we use state
transitional formulas in which for every
variable we will have you know two
logical variables capturing book both
the initial value and the latest value
or current value and we did know that
using the primal patient so X prime is
the latest value of any variable and X
is the initial value at the start of
some computation maybe at the start of
the method for example and we use this
hostile verification in which we have a
pre state and then a post date and for
verification we're just reasoning
forward so given Delta 1 the pre state
and some code we will compute the post a
from there so just as a simple example
if we have a pre state Delta and then a
language construct to construct a new
note in the heat then the post state
will be basically the original heat stay
in spatial conjunction with this new
node and the new node SSJ you will note
the variables here will capture the
latest value and then rest is just a
special variable to denote the result of
this expression okay and here are some
other rules in the system there's just
this is the roof of variable this is a
roof of assignment and then here is
where we check that the shape predicates
pure invariant is sound and we do that
by taking the definition of that
predicate and then subjected to a
translation to a pure formula and
checking that this body implies this
pure form layer so that we know that the
invariant given is sound and the the
main check is the check at the you know
method calls so that's the precondition
check so at every method call we expect
the precondition to whole and this is
done by that entailment here so the
current state must imply the
precondition okay so that's the the NPM
improver that we have
and then is in some sense since
separation formulas are substructure
logic this sentiment proved allow us to
obtain the residue or some frame
condition from there but for us to
propagate forward from there and then
the other approving part is done over
here where after analyzing the code of
the metal body we use it to check
whether the postcondition hosen on and
if it hosts we know that you're not
given the precondition the matter will
infect satisfy the post condition so let
me just run through a very simple
example of how this verification work
with the separation formulas this is
just an insertion procedure where
initially x is a Psalter linked list and
we are trying to insert a new node into
this sorted linked list so our
precondition will be X must be assaulted
linked lists and then also this VN here
work on will be a note with the value V
then we expect after this insertion the
post condition will have a sorted list
that is one longer and its minimum value
and maximum value maybe change you know
by taking into account the new not you
just inserted into this subtle English
and here you you have across the normal
base cases and also the recursive case
in order to work and I'll just highlight
a simple fragment of this how we do this
reasoning so we start with the initial
state the precondition and then the
variables will be you know based on
their latest values of X Prime and V M
prime will be the latest value X prime
points to the sorted list and vm prime
is the note we're trying to insert into
it and then in the branch where we have
this conditioner we will have a few XS
right our VN dot value which is
available here but x dot value will be
this X pointing to the sorted list we we
don't know whether this sort the list
has a note or not so what we do we
we unfold this definition so unfold to
the to the right hand side of the
definition that will in fact expose the
the note in this sorted list and then
use this so this X bar will now be this
minimum value and then this V here will
be a VN bar so that condition we
attached from the condition of that than
branch okay so that will be the state of
the system after you enter the den
branch of the conditioner next we have a
statement VN next being assigned to X so
where is the end of next the end of mix
happens to be this location here and
that will be assigned to the latest
value of x so what will happen is this
state will be updated to the latest
value of x so x prime then next we have
statement return the value VN as the
result of this method and in that case
VN happens to be this dis note here so
basically it will basically return this
thing but as a post condition so of
course the result will be updated to vm
prime then as post condition we also
expect it would be a sorted list the
result to be a thought the list so what
do you have to do is we take this
formula and see whether you would you'll
be able to flow through this formula so
if if the entailment tell us that this
thing will in fact fall into this
formula we have succeeded in proving our
post condition you know for this brunch
so as so the heart of the system is
really this entailment ruler and for
this enter improver we have an antiserum
which is the current state and also a
consequence which is the thing we are
trying to prove whether the current
state can imply that consequent not and
on top of that we capture the residue
that is any hits
that is not involved in covering this
consequence so the antecedent must
subsume all notes they are present in
the consequence for this implication to
hold and then the remaining nodes that
are not used to be kept in delta tree
and what the gut algorithm does in this
mpm improving is to make sure that all
notes in the consequence is in fact
subsumed by the antecedent Delta one and
when that happened we then convert the
formula to an aromatic check to see
whether the pure potholes are not okay
and we expect in general that the
antecedent and the consequent will be
given and then the entailment / will
return the residue that has not been
used by the proving the key step in this
end-time improver are basically they're
just three means that first we need a
way to match alias note together for
both the left hand side and right hand
side the antecedent and consequent so
either they are both de denotes or they
are both read predicates we match them
up and then we unify their respective
components okay so that's the matching
step then the other step is if the left
hand side happens to be a predicate and
then the right hand side happens to be a
node then we have to unfold the
predicate in order to match up the notes
so that so this is the so-called
unfolding process and then the converse
is is if the right hand side happens to
be a predicate it means the consequent
is a predicate and then the left hand
side antecedent contains the data node
both of these are alias then what we
have to do is we have the performer
folding task and that we make a
recursive invocation to the
entertainment procedure so we make a
separate and Pillman procedure to to see
whether this folding can take place here
is this a one-page summary of the rule
so the main steps as I said is the
matching the folding and then the
unfolding and then these are some
auxiliary
we lose to deal with this Junction and
extension quantification and also when
we have succeeded in this matching so I
don't I don't expect you to read this
rule in this one minute so just just
listen to me yes you know so we excite
succeeded in matching everything that is
in the consequence from the antecedent
then what we do is we will have an empty
heat on this side of the formula so this
is just a pure formula and then we will
make we will be a conversion of this
current state into aromatic form and
then pass it through a normal aromatic
proofer or plus all the pool okay first
all the P approval so let me just
highlight with some example you know
just to show you again be the steps so
the key steps so here is where we match
two predicates together so left hand
side has a predicate and then right hand
side also has identical predicates then
we have to match them up by unifying the
parameter so this n and n will be
unified and then substituted on the
right hand side so in the end we are
just reduced to this pure part which
will then be passed on to a normal
cooler maybe like that tree or in our
case we make use of a press bug approval
and also the cvd CVC like provable
aromatic proving so this is with
exponential variable we have a very
special way of handling free variables
in case there was a free variable on the
right hand side whenever there is a
matching we will in fact you know take
this matching where n is equal to m to
the left hand side so this is in fact a
quite important for example if you have
a so binding of free various will
actually move to the left hand side this
is quite important for example when you
have specification in which you
you have three variables tool in your
pre and post conditions so if your
current stack current state matches the
precondition then what you want to do is
to capture whatever binding that occurs
for the free variables into your current
state so that later on you can reason
with the post condition for unfolding we
will have a predicate on the left-hand
side and then a data a note on the
right-hand side and in that case we have
to unfold the predicate on the left-hand
side with the body and in this case this
predicate we have to part the base case
and the recursive case but the base case
because of this proper etiquette will be
eliminated so we just have the reciept
case and that will allow us to perform
subsequent matching so after this
unfolding the data not so in fact we
match up and then you're left with just
the rest of the linked list in this case
they will just do a further matching and
then you will complete for folding we
will have a predicate on the right hand
side and then either data node or a pure
formula on the left hand side and in the
in that case we make a recursive
invocation to this end pavement
procedure so we make a separate
entailment procedure in which the body
of this predicate is exposed and then we
try to match up the body and then and
then finally especially this is done in
this way because I allows us to make
instantiation of the parameter of the
folder predicate so that instantiation
to the parameters of the folder product
it will appear later on the left-hand
side of the formula for recursive case
is also similar because when you make a
recursive invocation the base case will
fail and then the recursive case will
succeed with normal matching of the node
and then subsequently is just another
recursive invocation and then the
binding that we get from
the parameters of the folded predicate
may move to the left hand side
especially if you involve free variables
if you if you involve bound variables
you will just stay on the right hand
side so at the end of this n palin
procedure we will in fact do
approximation to aromatic implication so
the entailment itself eventually reduce
to an impairment of pure constrain this
occur when the consequence if is empty
after all the matching and then the each
of the predicate in the final formula
will be approximated by sub pure
constraint I'll just highlight with an
example how this approximation is done
let's say we have a formula in we we
have this special conjunction and then
we have two notes okay and we have
variables x and y the way we convert
this to approximate the pure formulas as
follows X is is a pointer sorry this
should be a wire why should is also a
pointer and we know that since they are
data note there is going to be non now
so it has to be greater than 0 0 is
usually not now and because they are in
spatial conjunction we also add the fact
that these two pointers are disjoint so
x and y and y are in fact different so
we add this conditioning so that will
give information on the fact that these
two pointers are pointing to this joint
here if we have a predicate one thing
that we can immediately use is say we
have this predicate acts and then which
is the linked list with lang en' and one
thing we can immediately use is just a
pure invaded so we just can substitute
the pure invariant to this position
where there was a predicate but this is
kind of cool week in general so what we
do is before we actually do that we
perform an initial and full of the
predicate then we convert it in that way
so after initial
so we will have the base case and the
recursive case the base case we'll be up
you know X is a now and then n is equal
to 0 and then the recursive case is X
points to a note that is not now and
then we also know that n is greater than
0 so this this can be updated by just a
single unfolding and we only unfold once
we don't unfold more than once because
we experiment we unfolding more than
once you know we just the proving just
take too long to complete if you don't
do any unfolding at all you just use a
pure formula in the conversion then
there are certain things you are unable
to reasonable so the best option is just
unfold just once here is just some
examples that we try so so far we try
mainly a small examples but interesting
examples things like double English
circular Lee's salt the list also all
kinds of salting you know insertion
deletion Barbizon quicksort and then
various kinds of trees binary search
tree priority queue AVL red black tree
and all kinds of balanced tree and those
are just the verification time when we
use the Omega as underlying engine to do
the aromatic improving okay so that's
that's the basic system and I will spend
the rest of the time talking about some
extension that we need to make it more
expressive we have so called a facility
where users can give multiple proposed
annotation to each method and then we
have also facility where you users can
write landmarks or collision rules
relating the predicates okay and I'll
just show you why this is useful okay
say let's look at an example appending
poulos this is written recursively such
that we expected
the the two-parameter x and y and we
expect x to be non now because of this
initial access to the field of next and
then the precondition for this method
will be for example one precondition
will be both x and y are list segments
and they may have different lang and an
M but we know that this firstly segment
is not now so this requires this
precondition here and then at the end of
the method the list will be join up
because when you reach the last position
we will infect a sine Y to X dot next so
we have a joint list that we ok so this
is the normal specification that you
will give to this app and method so my
question is are there any other useful
specification that you may want to give
to this method no it's this
specification sufficient for your knee
or do you think they are more you need
more in general right so one example
will be what happen if x and y are alias
now if x and y are alias what it means
is x and y are equal to each other and
you only really have just one this
segment not to list segment and in that
case what is your post condition you
will be joining the last next few back
to itself right so what you end up is
you get a circular lease as a result
okay and for this to work you also need
an auxiliary condition where when you go
to the recursive call you use this
auxiliary proposed condition so now you
have three precondition pre pre post
condition for this method are they more
than you would like to have well what
happened if you happen to use quicksort
algorithm for example in which you
recursively sort the the you know the
two lists and then towards the end you
just do a joint right and a pen is the
joint will join the two softer this in
that case you need a
another proposed condition but this time
involving the sort that list such that
accesses of the list why is the sorted
list and also for this joint to result
in a sort of this the maximum value from
the first list must be less than the
minimum value from the second list right
and once you have that condition then
you'll get a sorted list after this
joint process okay and since this sorted
list is non now it's fine for accents we
expect it to be known now but for why we
will allow it to bid now sometimes so we
also would like to have a possibility
for why to be now and in that case the
postcondition is just exit south being a
sort of this okay so this this multiple
proposed condition is usual to
expressivity to your specification to
cover more cases more context so that
you could verify according to your
contacts and also of course a multiple
proposed by services are nothing new I
mean intersection types that people give
two types is the kind of multiple
proposed but based on types and then
also jml allow you to give specification
and then also separate specification
using the also construct is a kind of
multiple proposed the only thing is in
jml they will then much the
specification together into one so you
have to propose specification the
unlined system will merge them into one
specification by a union of the
precondition and then a conjunction of
that post condition based on the
respective precondition okay but we we
we would like to deal with these
multiple peoples separately and
explicitly other reason is because we
are using separation logic the other
reason is that we believe having
multiple peoples is a good thing because
by having multiple specification you are
you are able to write smaller
specification you know and that is good
for scalability in general
and the way we handle this is to expand
our verify improver to deal with a set
of state rather than a single state so
instead of proving with one single
residue as a result we allow our proven
to return a set of residue from that
proving okay and that in some sense the
node non deterministic outcome from
searching for a proof for this
entailment okay and if we get empty set
from this result it means the entailment
has failed that means we haven't found
proof such at the NPO manhole but if we
get more than one means there's more
than one way of succeeding in this proof
and also we modify the the verifier
component the hostile forward verifier
to capture a set of states during the
verification code verification okay so
that's the set of state to support
multiple proposed the set of state is
also used to support a land mass in our
system because quite often when we write
predicates some of them may indeed be
related just looking at the at the
predicate that we define the linked list
predicate that captures the lang of the
linked list and then the sort that list
predicate that captured assault that
linked list they are in fact related in
some way because every sort the list is
just an uncertain list so you expect to
be able to do this reasoning where if I
have a sorted list I should be able to
convert it to a normal linked list you
know that is unsalted because this this
is just a special case of normal English
so this kind of conversion rule we call
them land mass or we call them corrosion
rules and for example this but the color
conversion is necessary if you happen to
verify the bubble sorting algorithm so
in bubble sort you you don't know
whether something is salt or not
on the flag so if the flag you know that
you do the bubbling with you know sees
that there was no exchanges then you
know the whole thing is sorted but if
the flag dare say there was a change
then it means you know the the thing is
not supper and what you want to be able
to do is to colors the sort the list
will solve the case so that you know
your net result that is that is unsalted
so the user can provide this kind of
lettuce or collagen within the system
and we in fact allow in order to match
up with the way we do unfolding and
folding and which is the way we handle a
mass as well currently is we allow you
to write this kind of lemma the
left-hand side is always simple so
there's only one pedigree on the light
hand side but the right-hand side can be
complex so it can contain some other
heat a location other than the initial
predicate or not pointed to by the root
so we allow you to write this
implication so this thing implies a
complicated right hand side or we allow
you to write a complicated right inside
implies a simple left hand side so this
is the reverse implication or we also
allow you to express equivalence and
once this is given when we in fact will
prove that they are sound so we just use
our enter improver to prove that it is
sound by kind of co induction and then
and then this lemmas will then be used
by on time improver to do reason we're
reasoning where necessary ok and the
significance of this direction is when
you go from here you know from this side
to that side you allowed to do unfolding
so if you only give this rule you only
allowed to do unfolding but if you have
this rule you're allowed to do folding
which means if you have a predicate on
the right hand side you can then use it
in that direction and if you have both
lose you can do both ways and full laugh
or full right that's fine so that's the
implications of having this letters and
an example
of lemma that goes both ways is as
follows we saw the least segment bracket
earlier which is a segment that may not
be terminated by now often to reason
with just this list segment itself is
not adequate so we allow you to write a
slightly more general rule about this
segment they allow you to break one
segment into two segments so this single
segment could be broken in the two
segments with sighs I and J such that I
plus J will be equal to n okay and
you'll be join up by this extension area
and of course you can go both ways you
cannot only break your list segment you
can also join berry on this segment so
you go this way and that way okay and
the termination of doing reasoning with
this lemma is we have some condition on
well founder and a well-formed property
about the predicates and that also
applies to some extent of dilemma
allowing us to make sure that our
approval which terminate when we do this
n terminal separation formulas okay so
as an example of this kind of
equivalence lemma the way it is uses as
follows let's say we have an impalement
in which X point to a list segment and
also on the right-hand side and the
consequent X point to another list
segment and in this case what do we do
should we split the left-hand side or
should we split the right-hand side you
know or should we just match them up
together maybe the two segments are the
same length so we will match them up
together so in fact we will do a proof
search over this one is we just match
them up so we assume they are of the
right length and then we just match them
up and we just do this proof down this
way the other is we will unfold the left
hand size of the left hand side will be
unfolded and then after that we do this
matching up so this thing will be match
up with that one okay we cannot keep
breaking this segment if we keep
breaking this segment we will end up
with
infinite loop so we have some way to
control the doctor after unfold this
part will not be cold as any further and
of course the other possibility is you
do a folding with a recursive invocation
such that the right-hand side you know
is is being unfolded by the lemma and
then in that case you will match this
panel so these are the three ways to do
proof search involving this this segment
and hopefully one of them will succeed
and then we will have a proof of our
code you know and if it all of them does
succeed maybe they're more than one way
but usually there is only one way to do
the proof typically here is this some
experiments we did with a set of states
so these are the earlier examples and
then we you know in one case we turn on
our set of states together with multiple
propose and also lamico erosion and here
is the time it takes to do the
verification and then we also constrain
the system such that we only have a
single state don't have a set of state
then in that case of that examples will
fail because maybe those part will not
be explored by the proving so there are
some examples they will feel others will
succeed because maybe they don't need
any lemma they don't need any search and
also the time maybe a slightly faster
since you're not doing searching but is
only marginally so there's not really
much difference between the one with set
of states and single state ok so this
may be a preliminary conclusion that in
general we found this mechanism the
proof search the overhead to be blow and
also critical for some examples if you
don't have this proof search you will
fail for those examples so in this work
we we have built some tools we have
built approval itself for separation
formula which we call sleep and then we
have a verifier for an imperative object
based language we also have a verifier
for all language but this is really very
very prototype because it was done by in
student and intern of ours over a
three-month period so we will
we would need more time to refine that a
verifier for over language okay so just
as a conclusion just to recap them in
the main contributions in our world is
that we you know allow users to define
predicates about data structures
involving size and back properties and
with sophisticated invariance we have
shown you how to have a sound in
terminating entailment proving for
separation formula and then we also look
into various way or making the
verification expressive and automatic
with the help of llamas and as future
work we are looking into inference so
that we have more automation in the
process we are looking into debugging
facility so if say a verification fail
with what will likely has will likely
have some to that will allow the user to
explore where the failure occurs okay
and also our various extension we've
done the extension for all we would like
to extend it for other language feature
if possible for verification so that's
the concluding slide but that's not the
last like the last night of course that
I haven't talked about related work they
of course a number of related work which
we have draw inspiration from you know
the separation logic work from home
button and your group and of course this
is a kind of shape analysis as well so
we and also you know these are shape
analysis work and also related to this
of course in terms of shape with one
quantitative values like sighs and so on
Regina has done some work there was
published in says that we have followed
and also in the case of giant Walker
they have an IRC system based on linear
logic that
has some aromatic capably p and also
some way to define predicate except the
predicates as far as I was aware was
there not allowed to be recursive but
you can't define them in general okay
thank you we just use a call language
just a simple call language you know the
air conditioners method calls a way to
build objects is because we are just
currently is we're just building
prototype system so we just have a call
language of course we we also did a work
that for example translate see where we
take this CL Kampala and then translate
it further to our core language you know
but that that we haven't done use it for
verification purpose but is quite close
to what we have is no no no no at this
moment so so we haven't we have an apply
our work to a real language at this
point so at the moment is just based on
core language sorry
how large is it is it in so it's written
in M is related ml and then as back n we
can use different provers so the prove
us we have tried our line Mona CVC lie
also the Omega pressburger talk later
and Isabelle how large it is I I mean my
student has a details in see you build
it by own thing is very large
I see
I see well you see the one page
involving the integrin really doesn't
look so big if you just look at that one
pitch but of course a lot of details are
hidden but that's the essential part of
that Delmon bowie yes infants of pre and
post condition in general yeah so we
have we have another project that does
influence of both pre and post condition
and we go for this junk tiff domain so
would it because we find this junk to be
helpful in capturing things precisely
but in that inference engine that we had
we just deal with currently is aromatic
formulas we don't deal with separation
from this so it may be of interest to
also see what is involved to analyze
separation from about our infant engine
at this moment so if you gave if you
gave separation formulas like you gave
the shapes that you expect in pre and
post condition then I can envision that
we can use our inference engine to
listen for all the size properties from
there so that you don't have to write
the size property so those can be
no we haven't looked especially into
that but of course once you have the
size puppy it may be able to reason
about I know combination and so on from
their dilemma that we use for the
automatic how many of them us did you
take it you need for the kind of
examples of you showed us at least an
AVL is and so on and also how do you
discover the levels because if you
interacted curler education because you
see they right so at this moment we
expect the lemmas to be given so if they
are not given then the the verification
will fail maybe from the point where you
feel the user may be inspired to come up
with a master will you know that they
can then supply back into the system for
the verification to succeed at this
moment since we are dealing with small
examples we we just have having you know
a handful at mass maybe 12 or three lab
months in order to do the proving of
those examples but I expect this lemmas
typically to come from the library
designers so if if the design designers
were designing this predicate then they
will have a good idea what are the
useful lab mass for those predicates and
how the various predicates are related
to one another so once those are given
then our system will just prove them and
then apply them automatically